okay so imagine this
like alternate universe
and in this alternate universe
we have never had a male president!! 🤯
right
all 45 women. not a single man.
finally we start having some male nominees right
if that was the case
the most unhinged possible thing women could start saying would be
….you really shouldn't vote for somebody just based off their gender
but in this universe where that is happening
that's literally what they're saying to us
like that's again
that's the most unhinged possible
stupid thing you could possibly say
like are you sure you're the person who gets to be lecturing on that
who not only only voted for men for being men
but you also only allowed men to vote
and your god is a man and he had a son
and his son had 12 male best friends
but yeah
you should like
really not just follow people for their genders